The joe rogan experience.
It's just like there's a lot of dummies that we'll look at.
A guy like Mike Tyson,
I really think that they can kick his ass.
There are people that look at a guy like you look on stage and they get upset at
you for some reason they get upset at you for getting that attention to get
them,
so I feel like they should be getting it.
Thank God every chair,
every time one of them have stepped up.
I had a baseball bat of jokes,
you know,
my,
my reaction was always right on,
on time,
laser sharp and they was burnt out of the audience like,
like a cigarette butt and he's been in to witness it and I haven't been in the
witness.
You doing it.
I think you're one of the best I've ever seen him do it.
You inspired me and I seen the,
how
you took it out.
That was like,
well I'm,
I could go much higher.
Wow.
No,
what I'm saying,
I see you evaporate.
People says that me.
That told me that it's something that you definitely got to have as part of your
game.
If you're going to be standing up on the stage talking to people,
you have to have the ability to,
you know,
to do that.
If it comes up,
you've got to shoot them down and keep it moving.
You can't be haggling with them and you know,
cause that's going to break the whole continuity of the show up.
The guys that can just hit him with the hammer and keep it moving
best.
It's an unfortunate side effect of comedy,
but we started out freezing.
I were fucking comedy store veterans man and that was a place that nobody
patrolled.
There was no manager Shush in the room does the comedy store was run by the guy
on stage and occasionally dude's got kicked out because the comic would go just
get these fucking people out of here.
God Damn it would get,
it would get to the point where it was just you had to kick them out before the
show couldn't go on,
but there was always something there that plays is always drama.
I've had glasses thrown at me on stage there.
I've seen,
I remember when,
uh,
Holtzman got knocked out by Martin Lawrence,
his bodyguards.
God Damn,
that place was chaos.
I remember that.
I remember Eddie Griffin,
we were in the main room.
We had a show.
It was Martin Luther King's birthday and after the show,
this was the,
when the Dj came on,
this is the first time I heard this song.
No Vaseline.
Yeah.
And the Dj played it and Dr Dre and all of the dog pound and it was about Dr
Jura.
Yeah.
They were all there.
And,
and dre went up on stage and snatched the record off of the,
off the turntable and snapped it in half and that kicked off a riot.
Treach was in there to POC was in their trench.
Had that big change with the padlock on it.
He was swinging that over his head.
Oh my God.
This went on in the main room on Martin Luther King's birthday.
Wow.
I remember that.
Holy Shit.
Then my seatbelt places fucking crazy man.
His
last wave.
Flint,
there's surprise.
Laughs.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Seeing him where there's women out there that the counties,
I was in the parking lot.
What'd you was performing that night and she was standing by the back door and
this other chick came around and it was getting any come up about how they knew
each other.
Obviously she's,
she said that other chick did not taking that to come no more.
Richard shows
every time she hit,
another piece of jury came off too.
When she got finished,
all of this women's rings and necklaces and everything and her wig was laying on
and they was dragging her away man.
And then Richard Pride when on stage and did 20 minutes on what just happened.
Classics took it straight to the stage to stage,
to stage,
to stage.
What year was this?
They had to be eight in the eighties man,
you're like 89 90 something like that.
Could you imagine if you fucking videotaped all the time
and that was that.
That was the only mom.
She said they're not taking it to come no more of that.
Which shows pop,
pop,
pop and started firing on him.
How beautiful would that video be
to watch that watch the ass kicking to prior walking on stage to prior talking
about the ass kicking to pray all it went all three show.
Yeah,
I performed the 20 minutes on,
but just having outside,
I performed with Richard Pryor for a few weeks right at the end.
Right when he was,
when he stopped performing,
when he was in a wheelchair member,
when they used to carry him on the or room.
I had to go on after him for,
for weeks,
for weeks.
When he did that,
I always,
I was,
that was the only spot Mitzi always gave me right after Richard Pryor act to
reach it.
You would,
you would eat dick like no other time.
Yeah,
because it wasn't,
it was sad.
It was sad watching Richard know.
I mean,
it was cool because once Richard would open his mouth,
it was him.
I mean,
you know,
you could tell that he's,
and then it was,
it was a weird effect because you'd be like,
oh Yo,
he's still there.
He's still in there.
But then you'd be like,
wait a minute,
he's in there.
That's his body now.
And that's what he's,
he's kind of,
it's,
it seemed like he was more in prison after you heard him do stand up.
Cause it was a realization like this is a man who has his wits but does not have
his,
his motor skills and [inaudible] functions as bodily functions too to match up
with his wit.
Right,
right,
right.
And that was,
that just was,
even though he was funny,
you know,
he's sharp.
That just,
it was sad.
Yeah,
he would,
it seemed to me like there was a,
there was a disconnect too towards the end.
He,
I don't think he was completely lucid.
So when he would go on stage and talk about things like they didn't always make
sense.
And you know,
was,
uh,
it was,
he was dying,
you know,
and he would get this huge round of applause when he got off stage where people
just would say,
you know,
hey man,
when you look at him right now,
man,
there's not much time left.
And this is of the greatest comedians.
Maybe the greatest comedians ever walked the face of the planet.
Right.
The most influential I think of all time.
And you walk in and watching them as they're carrying him away and then they
introduce you.
Jeff.
Reggie gets on the piano,
ladies and gentlemen,
Joe Rogan from hardball on Fox TV.
Please welcome Joe Rogan.
And you go on stage and you have to do stand up,
have to Richard.
And it takes at least four or five minutes to get them out of the room cause
they're walking with them out of the room they have,
cause he can't really walk.
So they have to carry him and walk with them really slowly.
And everybody's clapping and standing.
You know,
like a war veteran just got off stage.
You know
who they just get those states.
Yeah.
It's good one.
[inaudible].